bonsoir mesdames et messieurs marcel
aubut avait convoqué les médias ce midi
dans un hôtel du centre-ville de
montréal
l'ancien président du comité olympique
canadien qui a dû quitter son poste au
lycée dans des circonstances qu'on
connaît voulait essentiellement
s'excuser le rang derrière martial but
la faye s'est excusé auprès de ceux je
devrais dire de celle qui l'a blessé
voilà dans une très courte déclaration
au patrice qui n'a duré que 5 6 minutes
à peine il n'a pris aucune question des
journalistes aujourd'hui n'a effectué
aucune entrevue s'en est tenue donc à
cette déclaration donnée avec un ton
très solennel il était visiblement ému
aussi est en somme marcel aubut tient à
s'excuser
on écoute encore une fois à ceux et
celles que j'ai blessé au dessus
je réitère mes excuses sans réserve et
je m'engage à tout faire pour devenir
une meilleure personne
vous disiez patrice en introduction
marcelo bus quittent du même souffle son
titre d'associé au cabinet d'avocats bcf
à montréal il dit qu'il reviendra
peut-être dans un autre carrière
professionnelle éventuellement après une
longue réflexion réflexions qui
commencent par la place qu'occupe la
relation entre les hommes et les femmes
dans sa vie
c'est du moins ce qui l'attend et nous
expliquer un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
mais je devrais le faire avec la
détermination et l'énergie que l'on me
connaît en me rappelant que la société a
changé et qu'elle exige un plus grand
respect entre les individus
plus spécifiquement entre les hommes et
les femmes en 45 ans de vie
professionnelle j'ai toujours vécu à 200
km/heure et ce sans arrêt et jamais je
ne me suis posé de questions sur mon
comportement en société
pourtant le rang 2 mélange il avait reçu
une lettre du directeur général du coc
lui disant arrêtez d'en brasser les
femmes arrêtées des touches et arrêter
de leur dire des changes déplacer donc
il ya dû réfléchir un peu en 2011 là
dessus bref il ya une des victimes
présumées victimes qui a réagi vous lui
avez parlé on en a entendu plusieurs de
ces histoires patrice dans les derniers
jours en des femmes qui sont sortis
souvent de façon anonyme confidentiel
dans les médias pour raconter leur
propre version de ces comportements
qu'on a dit douteux de marcel aubut
envers certaines femmes et la femme que
vous allez entendre on l'a déjà entendu
sur nos ondes
on lui a demandé de réagir aux excuses
officielles que marcel aubut a fait
aujourd'hui et elle ne semble
effectivement pas tout à fait satisfaite
on va l'écouter tout
j'ai eu un petit peu le goût de riz pour
tout dire et
j'aimerais croire que ces exclus sont
sincères mais je crois que c'est plus
une question de ne pas perdre de face
pour sa réputation pour maintenir
possible sauver sa réputation et elle
déballe ses 45 ans de carrière en queue
marcelo but aujourd'hui a résumé dans
ses excuses et maintenant ce qu'il dit
est bien c'est qu'il va a tenté de
refaire cette réputation patristique il
ira dit-il en thérapie on peut voir des
spécialistes at il dit merci laurent
ouais alors voir